we stand here for vanessa
stand here for justice we stand here
for every other service member
who's experienced sexual harassment or
assault
and did not feel safe reporting it
out of fear of retaliation
for years the department of defense has
talked about reform for years congress
has pushed the department of defense
towards the necessary reforms
some changes have been made but these
changes have not
gone nearly far enough
what is happening as a joke
just see the hashtag i am vanessa gideon
all those men and women in our service
suffering from sexual harassment
suffering for sexual assault
because they report it yet they take it
as a joke my sister's no
joke my sister's a human being
and i want justice and i want answers
because my sister did not do this to
herself
someone did it it does not want someone
it's various people
and if this could happen to my sister
what makes you think that can happen to
other service women and men
don't care about us you know there's
and this has to be fixed the system is
broken it's not working
or somewhere that's correct and we
believe that the person that uh
killed her is that person that sexually
harassed her
the one that walked into the shower she
was taking a shower she was in the
locker room
he walked in and sat there and she was
very creeped out
as one would be young 19 year old girl
why is a man walking in a shower
watching her who's her superior
so um you know this again shouldn't have
happened
and now she's not with us